avance dans l'affaire du meurtre de
Mamadou un jeune Blaisois de 18 ans tué
d'une balle dans la tête à
Saint-Herblain près de Nantes en
septembre dernier son corps avait été
retrouvé partiellement calcinée cette
personne vienne d'être interpellée dont
un homme soupçonné d'être l'auteur du
tir l'hypothèse du règlement de compte
sur fond de trafic de drogue se confirme
un reportage de nos confrères de
Télénantes c'était des représailles les
sept suspects étaient persuadés que
Mamadou la victime avait pris par la
veille à une tentative d'homicide allant
contre de leur clan il apparaît que
cette homicide est en lien direct avec
la tentative domicile qui était
intervenue la veille non loin d'ailleurs
du 38 rue vato audervallières et en
l'occurrence qui apparaît en l'état
actuel des investigations c'est que la
personne qui a été enlevée puis tuer est
une personne qui était soupçonnée comme
ayant participé de près ou de loin cette
tentative d'homicide et par conséquent
en l'occurrence ce serait par mesure de
représailles qu'il aurait été ainsi donc
enlever puis tu es dans les
circonstances que vous connaissez les
six hommes et la femme ont été arrêtés
la semaine dernière après une enquête
longue de 7 mois 4 était déjà en prison
notamment pour l'homicide d'un homme
devant un hôtel à Carquefou en février
2022 une autre personne a été
interpellée à Paris une à Strasbourg et
une dernière en Belgique ils sont âgés
de 20 à 42 ans tous déjà connus de la
justice pour trafic de stupéfiants c'est
fait là s'inscrivent dans le cadre d'une
guerre de territoire je crois que c'est
il y a pas d'autres termes autour de ce
point de Deal malheureusement trop connu
ici à Nantes qui est le 38 rue bateau au
Dervallières et en l'occurrence donc à
l'époque des faits il y avait une
véritable lutte entre deux groupes
criminels qui luttaient donc pour
pouvoir prendre la possession de ce 38
rue bateau un seul suspect a reconnu son
implication dans le meurtre il s'agit du
tireur il est âgé de 23 ans parisien
d'origine il était depuis peu sur Nantes
pour participer au trafic de la rue vato
les autres suspects gardent le silence
les six hommes ont été mis en examen
pour homicide volontaire en bande
organisée il risque la prison à
perpétuité